i have some absolutely must-see clips
for you today remember that as we talked
about before the break
uh some of the 2020 elections aren't
over the presidential election is over
trump lost but the senate is still to be
determined by two runoff elections both
in georgia both on january 5th the
deadline for registering to vote in
georgia
is today online and today by mail
must be postmarked by today december 7th
the deadline for absentee ballot
requests is january 1.
early voting starts monday december 14th
a week from today
one of those races is incumbent
republican senator david perdue
against democratic challenger john
ossoff now david perdue will not be
debating john ossoff because john ossoff
completely humiliated david perdue in
the last debate
here is a reminder of that well perhaps
senator perdue
would have been able to respond properly
to the covid19 pandemic
if you hadn't been fending off multiple
federal investigations for insider
trading
it's not just that you're a crook
senator
it's that you're attacking the health
of the people that you represent that
was absolutely brutal i considered
actually calling and reporting a murder
when i saw that
i've never seen anything like that and
purdue bailed on all future debates
because it was such a disaster but the
other race did have a debate yesterday
unelected incumbent senator kelly
leffler
one of the most corrupt senators in the
senate right now
uh has a challenger in rafael warnock
they debated last night and lefler
appeared to malfunction going into
dozens of repetitions of the same four
or five phrases
it was bizarre she looked like a robot
she didn't move and had this weird
sideways smirk on her face
she mostly refused to even look at her
opponent and
she repeated the same things over and
over and over again
no matter the question no matter the
topic
loffler leffler would just repeat
one of the four or five things that she
said throughout the entire hours debate
which i covered live for you on youtube
twitch and facebook now one of our
viewers
who goes by the name gaslit citizen on
twitter put this together at my request
you're going to see that no matter the
topic kelly lefler keeps repeating
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal chuck schumer chuck schumer
chuck schumer
the american dream the american dream
the american dream i grew up on a farm i
grew up on a farm
these are all unique instances from the
debate
nothing is repeated here take a look a
new deal
i'm fighting for chuck schumer chuck
schumer chuck schumer's chuck schumer
chuck schumer chuck schumer chuck
schumer chuck schumer chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi to live the american
dream the american dream of the american
dream the american dream the american
dream the american dream the american
dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream
the american dream and the agent of
change is my opponent
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock radical liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock is their agent of change
but all those things that you're warning
about would not be happening presumably
with president trump as president so
it almost sounds as though you're
conceding that that part of it has been
settled
and now it's important for the
republicans to to keep the majority in
the senate
to to have a divided government i was
born and raised on a farm i was born and
raised on a farm
i was born and raised on a farm i grew
up working in the fields
i grew up working in the fields i grew
up working in the fields i waitress
my way through school i waitressed my
way through high school and college and
i was the first in my family to graduate
from college
and i was the first in my family to
graduate from college it really is
bizarre and her use of this phrase
radical liberal
raphael warnock clearly something she
thinks will help her with the georgia
electorate and it may i mean it's
possible that she's doing this because
she can't actually justify staying in
the senate based on anything she's done
so she's just attacking her opponent
here are some instances of that and
check this out wrapping it up in a bow
with socialism at the end
democrats want to fundamentally change
america and the agent of change
is my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock my opponent
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock has partnered
with stacy abrams
my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock would be a rubber stamp
and my opponent radical liberal rafael
warnock is his agent of change you've
just heard
radical liberal raphael warnock but my
opponent radical liberal rafael warnock
is a socialist from radical liberal
rafael warnock or we can take the path
of socialism that radical liberal
raphael warnock wants to bring to our
country they want to radically change
our country
and their agent of change is radical
liberal raphael warnock they want to
fundamentally change america and
radical liberal rafa warnock is their
agent of change
look you've just heard radical liberal
rafia warnock
lie about my record i have never seen
anything like this
other than other than it did remind me
of the 2016 republican primary debate
where marco rubio's
software seemed to similarly glitch and
chris christie called him out on it
here's a flashback to 2016 when rubio
seemed unable to repeat anything other
than that same answer
uh about barack obama knows exactly what
he's doing take a look at this
and let's dispel once and for all with
this fiction that barack obama doesn't
know what he's doing he knows exactly
what he's doing
but i would add this let's dispel with
this fiction that barack obama doesn't
know what he's doing
he knows exactly what he's doing facts
here's the bottom line this notion that
barack obama doesn't know what he's
doing is just not there it is
he knows exactly where it is the
memorized 25 second speech
that's the there it is this campaign is
so important to the gang of eight bill
first
well here's the response if i think
anyone who believes that barack obama
isn't doing what he's doing on purpose
doesn't understand what we're dealing
with here
okay this is a president this is a
president who is trying to change this
country
yeah so that uh that was a very strange
event
yesterday's debate was completely
surreal so earlier yesterday you had
john ossoff asking questions of an empty
podium
because his opponent david perdue
refuses to debate him after ossoff
crushed him
and then you have kelly lefler just
stuck on repeat repeating the same
things
they both need to be removed and uh
kelly leffler also continuing to refuse
to accept
that donald trump won the election check
out how she handled
that question and there's a little
glitch in this clip which i apologize
for
yeah my my question is actually pretty
simple uh
yes or no senator leffler did donald
trump
lose election
you know president trump has every right
to use every legal recourse
available in our own state we've seen
time and
again that we have investigations that
need to be completed
so as you can see we did not get a yes
or no out of her
but she refuses to simply say well yeah
trump did
lose the polling i'm not even going to
show you they're all ties
you have you know i could say oh leffler
is tied in a poll and up one in another
and down one in another
and ossoff is up to but then down these
are all
what i call practically speaking ties
it's going to come down to turn out it's
going to come down to getting the vote
out so you can get involved you can
phone bank you can text bank you can go
and door knock safely if you are in
georgia and of course you can donate and
vote if you live in georgia as well
um so let's just consider these ties and
get to work
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because
magic spoon makes breakfast cereal that
you really can't tell apart from those
tasty sugary cereals that we all know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams
of protein so it's perfect for someone
on a low carb keto diet just anybody
trying to eat healthier and cut back on
the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video